halo infinite season 2 details are here
as well as an explanation for the forge
delay
343 industries has shared new details on
halo infinite season 2 lone wolves which
launches on may 3rd for arena
multiplayer 343 is adding a new map
catalyst which will be available on
multiple playlists at launch the king of
the hill and attrition modes will be
added to new playlists while the motion
tracker better known as radar will see
improvements to its outer edge detection
for big team battle the new map breaker
will be available on season 2 launch day
and in a very exciting development
multiplayer announcer jeff steitzer's
voice will be added for medals that
players earn big team battle also gets a
fix in the season 2 update for a bug
that caused weapon racks to spawn
asymmetrically 343 also announced that
it's implementing a change to csr so
that the progress bar now reflects
results from the most recent match and
not the entire season melee combat
should be improved too as 343 says
players will be less likely to phase or
whiff on beat down chances thanks to
network improvements additionally melee
damage is being decreased by 10 percent
on all weapons for the mangler
specifically players will need to hit
two shots and a beat down to earn a kill
additionally the ravager's base shot now
sees a damage buff for equipment the
drop wall gets a slight performance
increase while the overshield becomes
more powerful as well providing slightly
more shielding in terms of vehicle
changes collision damage aka splatter
for the chopper will be increased the
banshee's agility and damage output
meanwhile will be increased to help
players dominate better and finally the
warthog and razorback won't flip or
bounce as much with the season 2 update
you can see a full rundown of halo
infinite season 2 update highlights over
on gamespot.com and in other halo news
infinite's long-awaited forge mode which
lets players create all manners of
custom content missed the game's launch
last year and is likely still many
months away from release developer 343
industries has now explained the delay a
little more saying it was necessary to
ensure it reached 343's benchmark for
quality in a blog post the dev said
quote it broke our hearts to not be able
to launch forge alongside the rest of
infinite but to ensure it meets the bar
that we're setting for it to achieve
this massive overhaul to forge in
infinite just wasn't able to make it out
before the end of last year the new
version of forge will feature quote
another generational leap forward in
terms of its capabilities and the dev
added it will contain many of the
community's highly requested features
the mode is coming sometime during halo
infinite season 3 so it's still a long
time away from release members of halo
insiders will get to try it first and
provide input to 343 and according to
343 it will quote be worth the wait for
the forge community and fans of the
content they will be able to create and
before we close out 31 years after the
secret of monkey island and monkey
island 2 were getting returned to monkey
island this year the game's director ron
gilbert said on twitter that he's been
working on return to monkey island in
secret for the past two years the game
is being developed by terrible toybox in
partnership with lucasfilm games and
devolver digital and even though it's
slated for release this year there's no
word yet on a specific date or platforms
unfortunately i don't have an ounce of
nostalgia for the monkey island series
but let me know in the comments if
you're really excited so i can be
excited for you and also let me know
what you think about all of the new halo
improvements coming in may
i'll see you tomorrow